Lucia: 我们这里有啊
Lucia: 那个镜子太小了
Alice:薇薇你醒了吗
Jake:要门缝偷看我们
Alice:你要向开门吗
Alice:我能进来吗
Katrina: 这个动作有一点点碎
Lucia: 刚进来这里看
Lucia: 还没有看出来
Jake:你们接着跳啊
Jake:你们也要跳
Lucia: 我这边反光刚好
Lucia: 打在打在这个人上看不清楚
Alice:要不要把那个窗帘放下来
Lucia: 或者我们现在需要用到这个
Lucia: 这个灯吗
Lucia: 这样可能会好一点
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 我们前面应该还有一个大镜子
Lucia: 就更好了
Jake:我给你们补光吧
Lucia: 这样就能
Lucia: 哦可以可以
Tasha: 那个那个那个影楼灯
Lucia: 那个柔光板一定要加上
Lucia: 这动作感觉好陌生
Lucia: 是哈哈所以我要想要跳这个嘛去
Lucia: 可以跳worset
Shure: 如果我们看电影
Shure: 我们是在楼上看电影
Jake:看什么电影啊
Shure: 那我们很多想要看一看的电影
Lucia: 可以吃火锅
Shure: 集体观影
Jake:可以吃火锅
Jake:我就是光看电影
Jake:没有动作不好
Lucia: 可以把它投到这个上面吗
Lucia: 把这个视频
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: 这样是不是方便学一些
Lucia: 因为只要这个灯打开
Lucia: 就是他屏幕上就会有一个亮点
Lucia: 然后我有点散光
Lucia: 所以所以我看动作有点看不清楚
Jake:可以啊可以可以
Jake:投过吗投过吗
Lucia: 但有个问题是我们好像只能投5次
Lucia: 是不是应该把这个宝贵的机会
Shure: 就小米那个可以那什么
Jake:再找一下
Shure: 来解决一下
Jake:好你来解决一下
Katrina: 现在只剩了一张30
Katrina: 差不多了
Katrina: 再看一下
其他人：这标准的女士动作
Jake:确实
Lucia: 然后就要这边OK
Lucia: 下来这样的
Shure: 好像那个送孩子来上跳舞课的家长
Lucia: 我要换双鞋子
Lucia: 不行这个这个
Lucia: 等一下我如果戴着眼镜进去
Lucia: 是不是他就拍到我
Lucia: 乱七八糟的
Katrina: 差不多学到这
Katrina: 差不多啊
Katrina: 我觉得
Shure: 已经已经学完了
Katrina: 没有只学了一分半
Jake:好啊哈喽
Jake:早上好
Shure: 早上好叶之诚
Shure: 昨天的此言乐透
Katrina: 你确定学这个吗
Jake:啊你们怎么样
Katrina: 有意义吗
Katrina: 这个有点点小难
Katrina: 但是只要大家有决心
Katrina: 就肯定能学会
Shure: 你怎么还PV我们呢
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: 其实还有一个
Katrina: 我们今天看群里了
Shure: 稍微再低一点
Jake:这个不要动
Jake:就是这个要校准
Jake:你每次动一次
Jake:要校准校
Shure: 好现在不动
Shure: 这个简单
Katrina: 这可能学着比较有成就感
Lucia: 拖鞋都快让我跳的甩出去了
Lucia: 哈哈换一个
Lucia: 跟脚一点
Lucia: 着我能看清
Lucia: 这个腿要换吗不用换
Shure: 我的B站怎么不堪重负呢
Shure: 你发我直接点链接进去
Shure: 叫啥呀这个
Katrina: 这么偶像万万岁
Lucia: 我觉得这个不错
Lucia: 因为他的动作重复
Lucia: 重复率很高
Katrina: 偶像万万岁
其他人：这个不好玩
其他人：我们还在跳那个
Katrina: 你要跳那个
其他人：对我们要有挑战
Lucia: 什么刚刚那个时原版吗
其他人：这怎么好像有延迟卧槽
Lucia: 掉帧了
其他人：这太简单了
其他人：今天就可以出团了
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: 啊说反了
Shure: 广场舞级别
Lucia: 这次就爱心了
Lucia:  真的很难说短剧和这个谁尬哈哈哈
其他人：我说什么这个是不跳的蛮尬的
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
其他人：我他妈的跳操都没这么认真
Shure: 说实话跳这个是态度不行
Shure: 跳yes ok是能力不行
其他人：卧槽下蹲
Shure: 我们先拿这个热身
其他人：加油新中国加油
Lucia: 哦这是桃心
Lucia: sorry又错一次
哈哈哈哈哈
其他人：还他妈有
Lucia: 不是怎么回事
Lucia: 为什么又开始跑步
Lucia: 这运动量其实也不小呢
Lucia: 呜
其他人：这个太简单了
Katrina:  ：太简单了
Katrina: This is too easy.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
其他人：太累了
Jake:就学完了是吧
Jake: So, you finished learning, right?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Lucia: 他们已经这个顺利学会了
Lucia: They've already learned this smoothly.
Shure: 觉得这个没有难度
Shure: I feel like this isn't challenging.
Shure: 我们需要学学有一点东西的东西
Shure: We need to learn something a bit more challenging.
Shure: 哎我的b站又烂掉了
Shure: Ugh, my Bilibili is broken again.
Lucia: 这个我也复习起来能快一点
Lucia: If I review this, I can do it faster.
Jake:再看一下
Jake: Let's take another look.
Katrina: worth it的感觉是很早很早前的舞了
Katrina: The "worth it" feeling is from way back when.
Shure: 呦
Shure: Oh.
Katrina: 高中的时候就跳
Katrina: We danced it back in high school.
Shure: 你还没有开
Shure: You haven't started yet.
Lucia: 对对我那会大一的时候跳的
Lucia: Yeah, I danced it in my freshman year.
Jake:你没开
Jake: You haven't started.
Lucia: 所以其实也忘得差不多了
Lucia: So, I've pretty much forgotten it too.
Lucia: 但是比学个新的能快一点
Lucia: But it's faster than learning something new.
Katrina: 所以
Katrina: So...
Katrina: 呃我想想本来备选还有什么来着
Katrina: Uh, let me think, what else was on the backup list?
Katrina: 奔跑的青春和
Katrina: "Running Youth" and...
Lucia: 哎奔跑青春可以让他们去跳那个solo
Lucia: Hey, "Running Youth" can have them do that solo.
其他人：再跳吧我要解除封印了
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Jake:啊你要干嘛了
Jake: Ah, what are you going to do?
Shure: 要脱光膀子了是吧啊
Shure: You're going to strip, aren't you?
Jake:你要脱了是吧哦
Jake: You're going to strip, right?
Katrina: 那就跳这个黑色的
Katrina: Then let's dance to this black one.
Jake:声音可以弄大一点
Jake: Can you turn up the volume a bit?
Katrina: 我我已经调到最大了
Katrina: I've already turned it up to the max.
Katrina: 对这是教学
Katrina: Yes, this is the tutorial.
其他人：我就不用教学可以直接跳
Katrina: 真假哈哈惊呆了
Katrina: Really? Haha, I'm shocked.
Shure: 哎呀卧槽
Shure: Oh my god.
Jake:好了哦行
Jake: Okay, we're good.
Shure: 太sex了吧这个
Shure: This is so sexy.
Katrina: 这正常的爵士元素
Jake:来也跳啊
Jake: Come on, jump.
Jake:你们跳一跳
Jake: Everyone, jump.
Katrina: 2234
Katrina: 5 5678
Lucia: 哎怎么又校准一次
Lucia: Hey, why are we calibrating again?
Jake:因为刚刚有人没有开
Jake: Because it wasn't on just now.
Katrina: 刚开始是背过去的1234567
Katrina: At the beginning, we turned around, 1234567
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my God.
Katrina: 5678
Lucia: 原来如此
Lucia: I see.
Shure: 哪一步我不会了
其他人：太简单了
Lucia: 等一下这个是
Shure: 买喽买喽买喽
Shure: Buy it, buy it, buy it.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:薇薇你没开
Jake:你没电了吗看一下
Jake: Is it out of battery? Check it.
Lucia: 嗯
Jake:再来一次
Jake: Let's do it again.
Jake:对这就说一个15156对
Jake: Yes, it's 15156, right.
Shure: 行了这
Shure: Alright, this.
Katrina: music
Katrina: Music.
Choiszt: 太简单了太简单了
Choiszt: Too easy, too easy.
Shure: 567822345678323456784234567
Choiszt: 567822345678323456784234567
Shure: 洒洒水
Choiszt: Piece of cake.
Shure: 34567822345678
Choiszt: 34567822345678
Shure: 323456784234好
Choiszt: 323456784234 okay.
Shure: 二三四五六七八二二三四五
Shure: Two three four five six seven eight two two three four five
Shure: 六七八三二三四
Shure: Six seven eight three two three four
Lucia: 我们已经自动有了带教老师了
Shure: 是不是舞室都是这个样子
Lucia: 哦好热啊
Shure: 五
Shure: 六
Shure: 七
Shure: 八
Shure: 12345678